leaders of the day
the event was hosted by the new york
military affairs symposium it's about
two hours
good evening
it's a pleasure to see you and thank you
for coming
um
this is uh 50 years from 1963.
and
a basic question
troubles many americans
very simply why were we in vietnam
the chronology of that year leads to a
number of questions that will serve as
an introduction
and i will run through this chronology a
little tedious but i think you'll find
it interesting
in january 1963 there were approximately
11 000 u.s military advisers in south
vietnam
10 000 men and women in uniform more
than in january of 1961.
in december of 1962 senator mike
mansfield back from south vietnam gave
president kennedy a very pessimistic
overview
and recommended an early exit from
southeast asia
jfk was disturbed by his conversation
with his old friend and
supporter of
godin diem
the mansfield report was published in
february and greatly alarmed president
diem and his brother ngodin nu
in january a state department team
led by roger hillsman and michael
forrestall
concluded that the u.s should not leave
south vietnam
political and military success would
come in the longer term
january 2nd
35 miles southwest of saigon at ap bach
about 400 nlf vietcong forces
stood their ground against 1500 arvin
south vietnamese troops
five helicopters were destroyed and nine
others seriously damaged creating a
bitter controversy
uh abbak became a revisionist issue
recounted in two books that are of now
famous a bright shining lie by neil
sheehan and triumph forsaken by mark
moyar
question was opbak an arvind disaster
or at best a draw
and what were the consequences
in march the secretary general of the
vwp the workers party of vietnam
leiduan
sided with the people's republic of
china opposing the ussr in the
sino-soviet split
ho chi minh having apparently lost much
of his influence
was laid one in control in hanoi at this
time and what feedback did american
intelligence have on the power shift in
north vietnam
in
april 22nd the cia warned the white
house
of ngodin news increasingly
anti-american positions
in 1961
kennedy had approved a covert action
against north vietnam under cia
supervision
following maxwell taylor's
recommendations operation switchback in
the summer of 1963
operational plan
24a was shifted to the pentagon
question
what was the size and effectiveness of
covert operations into north vietnam in
1963
on may 8th south vietnamese police and
civil guards killed a number of buddhist
protesters in
in hue
during a religious demonstration
the dispute escalated setting the stage
for major unrest against diem
on may 12 the washington post published
statements by ngodin nu suggesting that
half of the american advisors some 6 000
men should leave south vietnam
reports of contacts between nu and the
north vietnamese were used in part to
justify a military coup
question
how serious were those contacts
is there north vietnamese corroboration
and are there documents on the issue
on june 12 the first buddhist monk set
himself on fire in downtown saigon
the image created massive revulsion
worldwide madame new made abrasive
statements to the press
on june 27th
jfk announced the appointment of henry
cabot lodge as ambassador to south
vietnam
and secret conversations were held by
cia officer lou connin
with opposition military leaders about
the overthrow of diem and his brother
on august 5th a second buddhist month
monk committed suicide by fire
and diem signed a martial law decree and
special forces ransacked buddhist
pagodas arresting over 1400 monks
question
was the buddhist crisis a legitimate
protest against the catholic diem regime
or was it staged by communist
sympathizers
on august 24th a state department cable
drafted by roger hillsman and approved
by the president informed
ambassador cabot lodge that the u.s
would not oppose a coup to remove diem
and nu
general min aborted coup preparations on
august 31st because of a lack of support
on august 29 french president charles de
gaulle
issued a statement calling for the
withdrawal of all foreign troops and the
reunification of vietnam as a
united neutral country based on the 1954
geneva accords
the kennedy administration did not
follow up and discouraged any discussion
with the french
question
why were both
jfk and lbj
adamant about keeping vietnam as an
exclusively american show
wouldn't the french proposal have
provided an acceptable exit for the
united states
on september 2nd kennedy interview was
interviewed by walter cronkite and
hinted that diem should fire his brother
new
he also stated i don't agree with those
who say we should withdraw
the white house then announced plans to
withdraw 1 000 u.s troops from vietnam
by the end of the year
on september 10th general victor krulak
and diplomat joseph mendenhall offered
jfk contradictory reports after a joint
mission to south vietnam
the military were satisfied and the
diplomats were pessimistic
on september 30 a mission by robert
mcnamara and general maxwell taylor
concluded that the war was at a
stalemate and cautioned against backing
a coup question
was the pentagon advice swept aside
on october
5th mcgeorge bundy drafted
national security action memo 263
announcing the expected withdrawal of
the bulk of u.s forces by 1965.
question
did this also imply rotating in larger
numbers of u.s troops before they were
to be withdrawn
finally
cia's luke conin
and general big min made final
preparations for a coup
on november 1st the palace in saigon was
stormed diem and nu were murdered
the u.s recognized the military junta on
november 8th
on november 22nd jfk was assassinated
on november 26th president johnson
signed off on national security action
memo 273
approving covert action against north
vietnam
in december 1963 there were
approximately sixteen thousand three
hundred military advisers in south
vietnam
that's the my introduction
and now
i would like to introduce our first
speaker mr john prattos
who is the author of many books and has
spoken to us many times
and his latest book vietnam
history of an unwinnable war is a
masterpiece of
research and and history please welcome
mr john prattos
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be back here
i have to say
uh
uh
one small correction to add my latest
book is the family jewels the cia
secrecy and presidential power
but vietnam unwinnable war is
about
exactly our subject tonight
and
i am going to
touch on some of its aspects briefly but
what i would like to do more than that
is to help set the stage for this
conversation that we're going to have
over the next two days
i'm going to talk about
what i see as some of the key
uh issues and developments of 1963
and i think
that you will hear a lot more about each
one of them from our other speakers
tonight
ed miller briefly
i'm sorry
opbach
was mentioned
at the outset of mr miller's remarks
and opbak was
primordial in the sense of vietnam as a
war
because it was
in a way
a pitched battle
although a small one
but between
generated forces on both sides and one
in which
the
national liberation front forces stood
their ground against the south
vietnamese army even with its
helicopters and its armored personnel
carriers and its
superior firepower
the question of
what
that meant in terms of the military
balance is one of the key issues
in 1963.
i argue in unwinnable war the history of
an unknown war
that
um
the vietnam conflict was characterized
by what i call an information gap
that is
that
uh
players and even on many sides of this
conflict did not have
a
close understanding
or even
know what the proper indices were
to
follow developments in the war and
outback is
a case of this
a second
aspect which is very important in 1963
and in particular
for identifying
whether the military balance
was shifting
had shifted had not shifted was the
question of the strategic hamlet program
the evolution of the strategic hamlet
program which had started about a year
earlier
was a
a key
difference actually
between the united states and south
vietnam and it was perceived in hanoi as
a threat
the north vietnamese were very concerned
that this might be a tactic and a
technique that might work against them
the dm government in saigon
in my opinion was overly confident about
their
work on the strategic hamlet program and
confident enough to want to sort of
close out the american contribution on
strategic hamlets and then the americans
were looking at the strategic hamlets
and
at first thinking that they were wildly
successful and then in growing doubt
about their success
this
concatenation
[Music]
is symptomatic of this kind of
information gap
you march forward into the summer of
1963
in washington
you have american intelligence
authorities arguing about
is vietnam a successful war are we
winning are we not winning and there was
a dispute in fact between the pentagon
and state department intelligence
and between the cia and the pentagon
about the status of the war in south
vietnam washington
ultimately
overrode
the objections of its own intelligence
people
to take a more optimistic view of what
was going on in south vietnam than
a lot of our intelligence experts felt
was warranted
this
raises
one of the contradictions of 1963
because
here you have
senior officials in washington
arguing that we should discount
intelligence that shows
that we're not winning the war but on
the other hand those same senior
officials looking at the american
relationship with the south vietnamese
government are saying that
the dm government is not prosecuting the
war to its fullest extent and therefore
there need to be changes made the
south vietnamese government needs to
make reforms in particular president
xium needs to
stop the nepotism and get rid of
family members of his
who are
entrenched in key positions in the
government
and that brings us to
a third of the key issues which is the
whole question of the coup
there is a lot to be said about the coup
in south vietnam and i think a lot of
this is going to be said here at this
conference
but
just to throw this out
and as a further illustration of this
question of what was happening in the
war and who was up and who was down
south vietnamese generals came to the
cia approached the americans first and
said you know will you support us if we
mount a coup to overthrow no dinzyam
the
question of vietnamese agency in all of
this is critical this was not an
american
fomented project in the sense that say
the bay of pigs was or
the cia's operation in guatemala in 1954
this was a suggestion
made by
south vietnamese officers and they
themselves perceived that they were not
succeeding in the war with the south
vietnamese government as it then existed
so
here's another factor one of these
issues the south vietnamese ranged on
various sides of the question of how
they are doing in the war
then
there is the question of north vietnam
and mr miller raised that briefly was
leswan in control
what were
the north vietnamese uh
interests relations perceptions
of the conflict in south vietnam of the
strategic hamlets of opportunity
versus
threat in south vietnam the year 1963
ends with a north vietnamese political
conference that adopts a resolution that
basically sets a policy of uh
prosecuting
the war in south vietnam at a new higher
level and the questions of what led to
that and who is behind that are also
central to the further history of the
vietnam war
now before i sit down i want to say a
couple of things about
the coup itself in terms of american
policy
here is a situation
where
the united states
wasn't starting with um
its own project
it was free to
accept or
reject participating in this enterprise
more than
the united states was in a situation
where
there were
grounds
for
going either way john f kennedy the
president at that time
had come
just off of the cuban missile crisis
less than a year earlier in which he had
triumphed in a major
uh nuclear crisis with the soviet union
and he had a strong political position
good political capital that he could
engage on either side of this question
he also had a wide margin a wide range
of
political maneuver
that he could
go into because
the united states public
in 1963
unlike in 1967 or 1970 or 1972 was not
had not taken positions on the vietnam
war there wasn't a large opposition to
the american war in vietnam and if
anything in 1963
there were
more
interest groups favoring american action
in south vietnam than opposing it
i did not mention and i should have one
key aspect of the year and that was the
buddhist crisis because that became
catalyst for much of the rest that
happened
and it's
important to note that in terms of the
buddhist crisis
the american press
now reported very
consistently and in considerable depth
on what was going on in south vietnam
around the buddhist crisis
and i submit to you it's a measure of
how little
american political
pundits and the american public were
interested in vietnam at that time
that despite all of this discussion in
the press there wasn't a greater public
outcry in the united states in the
summer of 1963 about what was going on
in south vietnam so essentially what you
had was
the kennedy administration with freedom
of action
a south vietnamese military that had
decided to act
uh
wavering an uncertain military situation
and a north vietnam that was poised
to
take greater action
my colleagues are now going to elaborate
on many different aspects of these
themes
thank you very much
[Applause]
my pleasure to introduce jessica chapman
she has researched vietnam
decolonization in the cold war she is
the author of cauldron of resistance in
golden diem the united states and 1950s
south vietnam
thank you for coming jessica
[Applause]
thank you very much for for hosting this
event
um
i'm going to throw a little wrench in
the chronological works tonight i think
by talking mainly about events that
occurred prior to 1963.
my contestation in my book is that you
can really only understand the events of
1963 in the context of
the longer term political events that
sort of led to american involvement in
the form that it took and led to
american support of modenziem um and the
policies that he pursued
i i find it fitting that
the opening question was why were we in
vietnam 1963 is an incredibly critical
year in explaining why it was that we
escalated the war in vietnam in the way
we did
but
it's not the answer to the question of
why we were in vietnam that's a much
larger question that covers a lot much
bigger span of time
i think we need to look back earlier
than 1963 to understand the events of
that year
and in fact
john prattos mentioned the information
gap that sort of dogged um
understandings on all sides of what was
happening militarily in 1963 and
throughout the war and i think that's
really pertinent to what i'm going to
talk about today because that
information gap was very much
present in vietnamese and american
understandings of each other and
misapprehensions of each other from the
very beginning of american involvement
in vietnam
in my book i explore
the chaotic competition for
post-colonial political control that
unfolded in southern vietnam between the
second world war
and the formation of the communist back
national liberation front in 1960
and i do that specifically by placing it
in the context of southern vietnam's
unique regional frontier character which
i refer to in the book as the wild south
which is meant to kind of parallel
the wild west in the united states and
evoke images of that type of frontier
environment
so today i want to explain that frontier
character very briefly and then today
i'm going to talk about how it factored
into modern dam's appointment as prime
minister so this says
or it may say
uh
it may say part one of this talk uh i'm
going to continue with these comments
tomorrow and actually bring us up to
1963 but my comments today are mainly
going to focus on uh notre dame's
appointment at prime min as prime
minister and the role that the united
states played in that and the way that
it interacted with this unique southern
character that i identify in my work
instability had really been a hallmark
of southern vietnamese society for
generations and this was true
even prior to its colonization by the
french
the mekong delta was marked by such
geographic economic social ethnic and
cultural heterodoxies
that one scholar has deemed it the least
coherent territory in the world
so all of these factors combined to make
the region notoriously difficult to
govern and that was true first for the
french then for the vietnam and
eventually for ngoden zam and his
american backers
this context helps explain why between
the 1920s and 1940s
while nationalists in northern and
central vietnam developed western
influenced country-wide anti-colonial
organizations like ho chi minh's
indo-chinese communist party or the icp
and the vietnamese nationalist party
millenarian groups took root as the
south's most powerful agents of
anti-colonialism
in a complex and often violent
anti-political or amp sorry
anti-colonial politics of vietnam's wild
south where much of the french and
american wars would play out
the huahau and kaudai
two politico religious organizations
often referred to as sects but i prefer
the term politico religious
organizations because it doesn't have
the same derogatory connotations and
it's actually more apt descriptor of who
they were especially when you consider
that they were
bunched together with the bin swin crime
syndicate
which was an organization with extensive
and sometimes very surprising uh
connections to nationalist politics but
nonetheless was not a sect in in the
sense that we normally use that term
so these three groups would be key
actors in southern vietnam's political
sphere
by the end of the second world war
these three organizations responded to
the dislocations that had been caused by
french rule and by japan's occupation
by balkanizing into armed administrative
units
the icp and other country-wide
anti-colonial organizations were in fact
incredibly weak in the south following a
failed insurrection in 1940
which encouraged the radicalization of
these three organizations and
facilitated the rapid expansion of their
power in southern vietnam
during the war the japanese occupation
further inspired them to become more
overtly nationalistic and anti-french
and with japanese support both the
kaudai and the wahao began to militarize
all three organizations worked
throughout the early 1940s to position
themselves to play a major role in
post-colonial vietnamese politics at the
end of the war
after the august revolution so ho chi
minh and the vietnamese revolution
following japan's surrender in 1945
vietman generals made an effort to
subsume southern vietnam's disparate
nationalist forces into their
revolutionary front so they tried to
bring kaodai hua hao and bin swin
military leaders into the the vietnam
front so they could be a united
revolutionary force but they often did
that by force and intimidation in ways
that um quickly alienated these southern
nationalist leaders
and that conflict drove all three of the
politico religious organizations into
alliances of convenience with the french
who paid them handsomely to defend their
regional strongholds across south
vietnam against vietnam forces
wartime french subsidies enabled these
organizations to grow even stronger
and enabled them to entrench
in their autonomous zones throughout the
course of the war
so by the end of the war they
occupied and controlled approximately
one third of the territory and
population of southern vietnam in
autonomous regions
so in light of this
southern vietnamese political context
that i've fleshed out very quickly i
want to discuss the m's 1954 appointment
as prime minister
historical debates surrounding
south vietnam's chief of state are
boudi's decision former emperor chief of
state of the state of vietnam's decision
to emperor excuse me to appoint ngnon
ziem
usually center on the extent to which
the united states was behind the
selection
some argue that the cia basically
ordered bowdai to name zm prime minister
others argue that ziem and his brother
ngodinyu maneuvered zam into power by
working over the long term to establish
his nationalist credentials within the
southern vietnamese political sphere and
that american preferences factored in
hardly at all
i see the answer to this question as
falling somewhere between these two
polls
bow down's decision to appoint godinsiam
prime minister of southern vietnam's
first post-war government was heavily
influenced by the united states
although baudai made his selection
autonomously
he wasn't forced into anything
he fundamentally recognized that the
southern government would need support
from washington in order to survive
and appears to have chosen siem largely
in response to pressure from the state
department and the cia
by the end of the war new had maneuvered
himself and by extension his brother
into a leading position within southern
vietnam's non-communist political sphere
equally if not more important though
were the activities diem undertook in
the preceding years to ingratiate
himself with powerful religious and
political leaders in the united states
and this gave him a distinct advantage
over other nationalist figures like
kaudai pope famcom pak
who had also earned a prominent position
in south vietnamese nationalist circles
but the key was although he had earned
that prominent position in the south
vietnamese political context he failed
to persuade the united states of his
capacity to lead
beginning in nineteen seventy three just
about one year before the french
surrendered at diane bianfu
a fierce competition erupted among
political figures in
saigon this was precipitated by the
french decision to devalue the piester
which sort of signaled an impending end
to the war
and so anticipating this end to the
french war southern vietnam's most
prominent non-communist nationalists
began to struggle to position themselves
to claim power
in the impending post-war government
hua hao kaudai and min swin figures
played incredibly central roles in this
process and famcom tech emerged as a
leader essentially on par with nothing
you
american officials however found calls
from fam
for radical concessions from the french
to hasten vietnamese independence to be
frustrating to say the least
ambassador donald heath accused pham and
his political religious allies of
displaying
emotional irresponsible nationalism
and concluded
it is a matter of extraordinary
difficulty to convey the degree of
naivete and childlike belief that no
matter what defamatory language they use
the vietnamese still be safeguarded from
the lethal communist enemy by france and
the united states
gradually throughout this process
american embassy officials shifted from
referring to hua hao kaodai and bin swin
leaders as nationalists
to beginning to label them things like
warlords plotters confessional groups or
even the junta
from those dismissive american
assessments of these groups
it's by no means obvious that by early
1954 if not sooner politico religious
leaders were making concerted efforts to
align their political appeals
with exactly what they understood to be
washington's cold war objectives
in vietnam namely an end to colonial
rule
and the establishment of a stable
non-communist government in the south
the french war was winding down
and it was becoming clear that the
ability of any southern nationalist to
assert leadership in a post-war
government
would depend on american sanction
huahau kaudai and vince when figures
therefore sharpened their critiques of
french colonialism and sought to
distance themselves from the french who
were paying them these subsidies
and they focused more and more on their
ideological opposition to communism
as well as emphasizing their histories
of violent opposition to the viet minh
and use that in fact to explain why it
was that they had made this marriage of
convenience with the french it wasn't
that they didn't have strong
anti-colonial credentials but they
needed to do this in order to
pursue the even more important goal of
ensuring that the vietnam didn't take
over the south
as washington searched for
anti-communist nationalist leadership in
vietnam that could inspire popular
passion
politico religious leaders desperately
hoped that they could provide the answer
however u.s officials remained wedded to
their conviction that hua hao kaudai and
bin swin figures were backward
irrational corrupt and incapable of
providing effective national leadership
of fam they wrote
the cow diocese pope although fond of
strutting on the podium in reality had
no political judgment
american officials called him
politically naive and unpredictable
and a charlatan with no convictions who
is lured by will of the wisp neutralism
by dismissing fam and other political
religious leaders in this manner the
united states rode off the most
influential power blocks and individuals
in southern vietnam aside from the no
brothers with whom they were more
intimately familiar
indeed american officials positive
assessments of norenziem
contrasted sharply with their negative
opinions of fam
they lauded his unquestioned integrity
his sincerity nationalism and honesty
and so bowday appointed zam prime
minister
in hopes of simultaneously satisfying
the united states and appointing
somebody that had sufficient nationalist
credentials within the southern
vietnamese political sphere that he
could hopefully rally other south
non-communist southern nationalists
behind the new government
at the time of his appointment many of
them's competitors took it upon
themselves to caution american officials
about what they saw as his troubling
shortcomings
one warned that ziem's high moral
character and personal integrity did not
compensate for his almost total lack of
professional competence and
administrative experience
and feared that dm's narrow sectarian
approach would alienate the country's
other non-communist nationalists
others warned that he lacked popular
appeal
and perhaps presciently was too insular
and unseated unsuited to leadership
many french officials shared these
concerns and strongly cautioned bowdai
in the united states against pursuing
zam's appointment and continued to work
against cm trying to bring about an
early end to the sam experiment which
i'll talk more about tomorrow
but during summer of 1954 u.s officials
themselves had little more than a dim
hope for zm and south vietnam's
non-communist future
shortly after zam's appointment u.s
council robert mcclintock cabled to
secretary of state john foster dulles
boudie's action in requesting that
gnodenziam form a government has totally
failed to arouse the enthusiasm of the
vietnamese people so essential if the
war effort and the national army are to
get necessary support
ambassador douglas dillon described zam
with the following mixed review
he impresses one as a mystic who has
just emerged from a religious retreat
into the cold world which is in fact
almost what he has done
he appears too unworldly and
unsophisticated to be able to cope with
the grave problems and unscrupulous
people he will find in saigon
yet his apparent sincerity patriotic
fervor and honesty are refreshing by
comparison and we are led to think that
these qualities may outweigh his other
deficiencies
the grossly unrealistic attitude to
current problems in the past appears to
have improved
on balance we are favorably impressed
but only in the realization that we are
prepared to accept the seemingly
ridiculous prospect that this yogi-like
mystic could assume the charge he is
apparently about to undertake only
because the standard set by his
predecessors is so low
in short american officials had serious
doubts about zam's leadership abilities
but they embraced him as the candidate
who is most likely to unify south
vietnam and prevent communism from
spreading there
but the task of unifying and pacifying
southern vietnam in the wake of the
geneva conference that ended the french
war would be a heady one for any leader
much less one with the limitations
attributed to the new prime minister
zam returned to saigon in june of 1954
after a long absence to a site of near
anarchy
he took control of a weakly defined
political entity that lacked the
institutions and organization required
to run a centralized government
when he took power these three politico
religious organizations collectively
controlled approximately one-third of
the territory and population below the
17th parallel
within their autonomous zones they
collected taxes elected their own
officials and maintained their own
fairly
strong militaries
the bin swin had a monopoly over saigon
chilean vice industries running
prostitution rings and casinos trading
in opium
illegally imposing quote unquote road
safety taxes in the roadways in and out
of saigon
in 1953 ben swim leader purchased from
the saigon or purchased the saigon
challenge police concession from baodai
for over 1.2 million
which enabled his forces to rove the
city without even nominal oversight
a number of other destabilizing factors
compounded sam's difficulty
in consolidating power over remarkably
fractious south vietnam
the national army rested under the
independent control of the francophile
general nguyen van hin
who had organized an early coup attempt
against the the prime minister although
unsuccessfully
so the way ziem attempted to deal with
this domestic political context was to
impose a very draconian divide and
conquer policy almost immediately that
pitted him against these political
religious organizations that held such
prominent positions in the south and he
prevailed very quickly in ways that i'll
talk more about tomorrow
in defeating his domestic political
opposition oppressing and suppressing
all of his opponents but he did so at a
serious cost and he did so in a way that
really framed his administration around
that need to eliminate and suppress all
political opposition
and i want to highlight here that it was
opposition from these political
religious organizations and their allies
that i've been talking about
and not communist opposition that pose
the greatest greatest challenge to zm's
success in the early years
it was the campaign
i'm sorry indeed the campaign against
communists that largely defined ziam's
government was in fact developed to
combat the threat posed by these three
organizations that i've been talking
about and other individual political
figures who allied with them during the
first two years of his government
and it always targeted a much broader
range of political opponents than just
communists
zam was so determined to silence
political threats
that he forced his rival fam komtak to
seek exile in cambodia by late 1956.
this move was intended
to eliminate opposition and suppress
dissent against his government
but it ultimately backfired to generate
discontent amongst kaudi followers and
you can see here this is the sort of
state of affairs in 1957 ngodenziam is
on tour in the united states shaking
hands with eisenhower at the point in
american history where he is viewed as
america's miracle man in vietnam for
having managed to consolidate his power
in the amazing way that he did by 1957.
however back in vietnam you see
cowdy followers protesting the exile of
famcom tech in ways that would fuel
opposition within that community
of non-communist nationalists to modern
dam's government beginning in those
early years in ways that would ramp up
later and in some ways contribute to the
political crises that zam experienced in
1963.
so i'm going to talk more tomorrow about
how ziam dealt with his antagonists
among the cow died of wahaw and bin swin
and importantly some of the lessons that
he learned and implemented from his
apparent triumph against them
and those lessons of course i argue led
him to pursue policies that only
contributed to the political crisis that
brought down his government and ended
his life in 1963.
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much for a great lecture
um i'd like to introduce edward g miller
who is associate professor of history at
dartmouth college
his latest book is miss alliance
godin diem the united states and the
fate of south vietnam published this
year
um i'd like also to express my thanks to
bob miller and bob rowan and and
everyone else here at
nymas for for putting on this conference
i'm really looking forward to tonight
and and our discussions tomorrow
um i have to begin with a warning as you
can probably tell um i've been battling
a cold this week and i believe i have
the upper hand
but as a vietnam war historian i'm very
leery of premature predictions of
victory
um
put differently uh i i don't expect to
defeat this cold in the next 15 minutes
um but i hope not to lose in that time
uh as is
i'm not going to say that either
um
my remarks tonight are uh are drawn uh
from my recently published book um that
bob mentioned um if we could get the uh
the first slide up here please you'll
you'll see the the the title there
i've got the clicker does will this work
no
okay
um
there it is
the main objective of this book which
was published in march uh by harvard
university press is to provide a new
interpretation of modern siem who of
course was the the founding leader of
south vietnam and i also want to suggest
uh what i think is a different way of
thinking about dm's alliance with the
united states and a different
explanation for the rise and fall of
that alliance
um i'm going to begin with a couple of
images one of which will be extremely
familiar because jessica just showed it
to you
this of course as jessica indicated is a
picture taken during zm's official visit
to the united states in 1957
and there are a couple interesting
things about this picture one is that
it's taken at the airport in washington
dc
and and president eisenhower is at the
airport he actually came out to the
airport to greet sam when he arrived
this is a very rare honor to be bestowed
on a foreign leader on a visit to the
united states
during this visit diem also addressed a
joint session of the u.s congress he
received several honorary degrees from
multiple u.s universities he even got a
ticker tape parade down broadway i mean
it's kind of imagi hard to imagine any
foreign leader receiving that kind of
honor today maybe somebody like nelson
mandela
this suggests that sam was not just
another foreign leader or just another
foreign ally he was really seen as a
hero in 1957
however if you fast forward to 1963
they're very different pictures coming
out of south vietnam i'm sure all of you
have have seen this very famous
photograph this was taken of course
during the major political crisis known
as the buddhist crisis in the spring and
summer of 1963
this involved protests as john indicated
led by buddhist monks against the zam
government
this picture taken by the journalist
malcolm brown was the most famous act of
protest
the monk tikwang duk immolating himself
zam eventually crushed these protests by
force in august of 1963
but of course that didn't end the
political crisis in south vietnam and
two months later
as john indicated south vietnamese
generals launched a coup ziem and his
brother odin you were captured and
executed
the evidence shows very clearly that the
u.s government the kennedy
administration encouraged the generals
to carry out the coup uh the u.s did not
sanction the the assassinations i think
that's quite clear from the evidence but
but the u.s did endorse the coup so in
contemporary parliaments this is a case
of the united states switching from this
policy of very strong support for zm to
a policy of regime change
now of course this is certainly not a
unique case in the history of u.s
foreign relations or even in the history
of the cold war there's there's plenty
of examples of the us attempting to oust
foreign leaders with whom whom it had
previously supported with with varying
degrees of success
however i i do think that the case of
xem and the rise and fall of this
relationship does have some distinctive
features which makes it worthy of of
closer study
perhaps the most obvious is just that
ziem's death is clearly a major event in
the history of the vietnam war it leads
directly to the massive escalation of
the vietnam war escalation by both
communist leaders in hanoi and then
subsequently by lyndon johnson and the
united states so so it's a very
important event um on its in on its own
merits in that sense
the the other reason i think it's
important is because zm was not just
another us ally for a while he was
really seen at least in some circles as
a model u.s ally so so the extent of
sam's transformation in american eyes is
quite remarkable how does he go from
being the miracle man of south vietnam
to being an obstacle that had to be
removed
and so this is what my book attempts to
explain
and i'm of course far from the first
scholar uh to write about tm jessica is
also not the first scholar to write
about jim there are many who have come
before us um but i think my
interpretation does differ from from
most of the older scholarship in a
couple of key ways uh one way has to do
with sources uh the existing scholarship
uh until very recently uh relies mainly
or exclusively on u.s materials um i
used a great many u.s sources in my
research but i also used a lot of
vietnamese archival sources i did
research in vietnam
including in the south vietnamese
government archives the south vietnamese
state no longer exists but the archives
are still there at least some portion of
them are still there and they are now
accessible to to researchers
so so that's one thing that's different
about my book
uh but i think an even more significant
difference has to do with the way i
interpret zim and his ideas and policies
uh until now i think that most of the
writings on jim until very recently
there's there's an i think a number of
of us who are trying to interpret
xamarin in a different way but in until
the last few years i think most of the
writings on exam were frankly quite
simplistic there were a certain number
of stock caricatures of ziem that kept
that keep coming up again and again in
the scholarship
some authors have portrayed him as an
american puppet they argue he was
created by the united states and and
therefore had no agenda of his own
except preserving his own power
another very common interpretation is
that zam was a quote unquote traditional
leader a mandarin a pre-modern guy who
somehow got stuck in the 20th century so
according to this museum was was
atavistic and anti-modern and therefore
not really interested in things like
development or nation building he just
wanted to turn back the clock
a third interpretation uh that's out
there is much more sympathetic to zim
this view holds that yes zam was
traditional he was sort of this
latter-day confucian sage but but that
was actually okay because according to
this view what vietnam needed was a
traditional ruler because vietnam was a
quote unquote traditional society
my view is very different from all of
these interpretations i don't find any
of these existing interpretations
convincing for two reasons first there's
not much evidence to suggest them in the
discussion i can uh say more about that
if you're interested
but my real beef with these
interpretations is i don't think they're
very historical and and what i mean by
that is they they really make no attempt
to understand ziem in the actual
historical context in which he lived his
life and this of course was early 20th
century vietnam
i think another thing another problem
with these interpretations is that they
deny zm's agency in these these
conventional accounts sam really has no
independent ideas of his own he's just a
creation of american power or a creature
of tradition
so what is the alternative how do we
gain a more historical understanding of
zim well in in my book i try to do three
things towards this this larger
objective the the first thing i do is i
try to understand them in the actual
historical context in which he lived and
this means connecting zim's life and
career specifically to colonialism and
empire ziam lived most of his life
during the period of french colonial
rule in vietnam and he began his
political career as a functionary in the
french colonial state now this isn't to
say that zam was pro-french or that he
was anti-nationalist in fact he was very
nationalist he was a strike critic of
the french colonial state
but even his nationalism was heavily
shaped by the colonial context in which
he lived and operated and in this regard
zam is really no different from
other members of his generation of
post-colonial leaders across the third
world people like sicarno or kwame
nkrumah or even somebody like ho chi
minh i would argue is very shaped by the
colonial context in which he came of age
so that's the first thing i'm trying to
do is connect them to colonialism and
empire the the second major objective
here is to try to understand sam's ideas
about development and nation building
as i said a lot of scholars have tried
to suggest that jim was uninterested in
these things i do not i argue in the
book that zm was a man who had a plan he
had very elaborate ideas about different
aspects of nation building he had very
definite ideas about things like
agrarian reform resettlement of the
rural population this was a very
important concept for zamini pursued it
very ardently while he was in power the
building of new communities the m had a
lot of ideas about these things
government reform the creation of a
republic the republic of vietnam that
zam proclaimed in 1955 this was very
important to him elections a
constitution democracy zam spent a lot
of time talking about all of these
things
uh finally sam's internal security
policies and counterinsurgency
strategies these were also
nation-building
aspects for exam these were aspects of
sam's nation building policies and in
the book i examined all of these these
different policy areas in detail so
that's that's sort of the the second
uh major contribution uh that i see
coming from the book
the last and perhaps most important
contribution is to explain why in the
long run this nation-building agenda of
ziem's was not successful
and here i think it's important to point
out that my book is neither a
celebration nor a condemnation of xem i
think most of the existing scholarship
does fit into one or the other of those
those two categories i don't see zm as
being either a runaway success or a
total failure
i think his record was mixed in the end
i see him having more failures than
successes but he did have some successes
probably his most significant success
had to do with what i would refer to as
as state building state building being a
subset of the larger project of nation
building in expanding the administrative
capacity of the south vietnamese state
in creating a new republic setting up
new institutions expanding uh and
strengthening the the south vietnamese
bureaucracy establishing new laws and
regulations these were no mean
achievements um and the things that zam
did in these areas were significant
however despite these gains in the areas
of state building zam ultimate had two
big problems that i think he couldn't
overcome
the first problem was that his ideas
about nation building did not mesh very
well with those of his american allies
this is why i argue that in the end the
alliance between the u.s and dm was a
misalliance it was a it was a bad match
uh their two approaches were just not
very compatible sam was very
anti-communist and of course the
americans were fine with that but he was
also very anti-liberal so when you look
at his ideas about things like community
agrarian reform democracy
he's using in some cases the same words
that the americans are using but the
meanings are very different and the
prescriptions and the policies that he's
advocating are very different from those
advocated by his american allies
so so that's one big problem that sam
has and one big cause of his
his uh his ultimate downfall the other
one was that his nation building
programs encountered a lot of resistance
from his his fellow south vietnamese uh
zm as i said did have some success in
the area of state building but nation
building is never just about state
building in order to be successful in
nation building you also have to
critically pursue what i refer to as
identity building on forging ties
between the people you want to govern
and the institutions that you have
created or are trying to strengthen and
in general siem was just not very good
at identity building
i think this was very apparent in the
countryside where his policies produced
a lot of resistance resentment and fear
this is especially the case as a result
of his resettlement programs uh things
like the agriville program rolled out in
1959 this attempt to create
new rural communities these massive sort
of farming plantations in the mekong
delta uh we're done with a great deal of
coercion and and were also shot through
with corruption so this really created a
led to a popular backlash and this was
something that the communists exploited
to great effect when they launched their
uh their insurgency against them in 1959
and 1960.
um zm's shortcomings in the area of
identity building were also apparent in
his dealings with fellow vietnamese
anti-communists
um on this point uh i think i'm perhaps
both similar and and different from some
of the claims that jessica has advanced
here in the early years iczm is actually
winning support from some important
groups of south vietnamese
anti-communists uh he was relatively
successful in winning support among his
fellow catholics
army officers were a very important
group for zim during his first years in
power and he was very good initially at
winning over uh key members of the the
arvin officer corps
some urban south vietnamese nationalists
even some buddhist groups zam's
relations with institutional buddhist
groups in his early years in power were
actually pretty good
unfortunately for zam by the early 1960s
he had alienated many of these former
supporters and by 1963 of course many of
these groups are going to support or
actually participate in his overthrow
that's certainly the case with the the
generals who lead the coup against them
all of those generals had formally been
zamasu they had all formally supported
him in one way or another
and it's certainly true of the buddhists
who as i said earlier had pretty good
relations with him
so to sum up the basic argument of the
book nation building i think was a
really important element in the history
of the ussm alliance on the one hand the
differences between american ideas about
nation building and zam's ideas created
a lot of tension in the alliance
on the other hand sam's actual nation
building policies also generated a lot
of resistance within south vietnam and
what you see in 1963 is these two
aspects of the contest over nation
building south vietnam coming together
and this is what i think leads to both
the dissolution of the alliance and the
overthrow of of the government
so that's the argument of of the book in
a nutshell um there's a great
more material that's in the book uh
which i don't have time to talk about
now
because the topic of the conference is
1963. i want to just finish up with a
couple of remarks about events that took
place in 1963 and talked specifically
about the buddhist crisis and i'll have
more to say on this and and some other
1963 related things tomorrow
uh the crisis the buddhist crisis as
john indicated began in may of 1963
it was precipitated by the emergence of
an anti-zam protest movement led by
buddhist monks
i did a lot of research on the buddhist
movement and on zam's response to the
crisis which is presented um in the book
in the last couple of chapters and
there's a couple of key findings that i
i argue
for which i think are very different
from from the conventional wisdom on the
subject the the first of these is that
the buddhist crisis was not just a
religious conflict uh the conventional
view was that the 1963 crisis was a
straightforward case of religious
discrimination or even persecution
during the crisis the buddhists accuse
them of this of trying to suppress their
religion
there were definitely officials in this
yemen government including members of
zim's own family who were guilty of this
some of them's brothers in particular as
i'll note in a moment
however the roots of the crisis went
much deeper than amir response to
religious discrimination the buddhist
movement in 1963 is not an isolated
event in the history of vietnamese
buddhism it's actually an episode in a
much larger longer running phenomenon
known as the vietnamese buddhist revival
this is something that began decades
earlier in the 1910s and 1920s when some
buddhists felt that vietnamese buddhism
had become too distant from the lives of
ordinary vietnamese laypeople and so you
have this reform movement in vietnamese
buddhism where monks and nuns are
arguing they need to get out of the
pagodas get involved in the affairs of
the world and from the beginning this
revival had both religious and political
goals on the one hand there was this
emphasis on reviving buddhism through
social activism so you see monks
becoming much more involved in lay
education and social work
on the other hand the buddhist revival
was very explicitly nationalist and in
particular buddhist began to talk about
national buddhism their argument was
that vietnam was a quote unquote
buddhist nation and so therefore vietnam
in order to survive and thrive in the
modern world had to cultivate its
buddhist traditions this nationalism had
very clear political implications
all of the leaders of the 1963 protests
against zam are supporters and
participants in this vietnamese buddhist
revival
now during zam's first years in power as
i said he actually had pretty good
relations with these buddhist leaders
with these buddhist nationalists he was
cultivating them he was actually
providing money for them to build new
pagodas to form new organizations
however after 1960 some buddhists become
more skeptical of zam and they begin to
see his nation-building policies as
hostile to their buddhist reform agenda
so so that i think is one very important
aspect of the 1963 crisis that's been
overlooked
the other very important aspect that
i'll just briefly mention here has to do
with conflicts within ziem's family
among the members of the family and
specifically among his brothers
the buddhists were initially upset in
1963 not by ziem but by certain actions
taken by his older brother
as many of you know was the archbishop
of the city of hue which is a one of the
larger cities in central vietnam and
it's significant that the buddhist
crisis begins in way that the first
protests against the regime are in way
they were directly the result of actions
taken by mold intol the the episode that
john alluded to that takes place on may
8 1963
ostensibly it's about religious flags
about the police in play in their
attempt to suppress the buddhists in
their their they want the buddhists
wanted to display religious flags on
visak day which is the holiest day of
the buddhist calendar
um but it wasn't really about flags it
was really about london
uh one of them's other brothers his
younger brother lord and gun had
actually tried to had ordered the police
to stand down and and not to
uh crack down on the buddhists and he
was overruled by toll so so that initial
incident in way is very much sparked by
by by modern top and by buddhist anger
with him
sam's first reaction when the buddhist
movement begins is actually to try to
settle it by negotiation
and this makes perfect sense given his
prior relations with these buddhist
leaders he knew who these guys were at
least some of them
he actually negotiated a deal in early
june 1963 with buddhist moderates but
the deal is then blown up by yet another
of zam's brothers
who along with his wife the infamous
madame you uh convinced them to take a
hard-line approach so so there's this
very important shift in dam's thinking
over the course of the buddhist crisis
and there are a couple of different
actions here that are important on the
one hand madame you
comes out with an attack on the
buddhists of a verbal attack on the
buddhist at a key moment in early june
this leads then to the self-immolation
of tikwang duk
when tikwang duk initially proposed to
burn himself uh to buddhist leaders they
turned him down they said no we don't
need this we're negotiating with the
government this is going to be fine but
then after the news blow up the the
negotiated accord between the buddhists
and the government uh then the buddhist
leaders turn back to modern uh or they
turn back to ti guang duk um the
decision to um
to have tikwang duk burn himself on june
11 1963 was made the night before on
june 10th so what had happened was tic
wong duk had proposed this a couple
weeks earlier buddhist leaders said no
we don't need you to do this but then
they made that decision on june 10th no
we do need you to do this
and one of the sources that i used was
the memoir of one of the the young
buddhist acolytes who was called into a
meeting of the buddhist leadership and
they said we've decided that that um the
reverend tikwangduk is going to burn
himself to death tomorrow morning you
have to go find him right now and make
sure he's still okay with this
um the the larger point here is that
these conflicts within the the family
are very important they intersect with
this this buddhist reaction to zam's
nation building programs in in 1963 and
they contribute directly i argue uh to
his downfall
okay by way of wrapping up
my argument here is again about the
centrality of ideas about nation
building in the history of the vietnam
war and specifically in the history of
the zhiyun regime
i don't think sam was either a puppet or
a creature of tradition as he's often
been represented he had his own ideas
his own vision for nation building in
south vietnam it was not a liberal
vision and ultimately it was not a
successful vision but he did have an
agenda and it's something that
historians need to take seriously
uh in his efforts to pursue this vision
sam was not entirely lacking in success
again especially in the area of state
building but in the area of identity
building he was much less successful and
and this is particularly apparent i
think in episodes such as the buddhist
crisis of nineteen sixty three
at the same time zam's nation building
ideas also lead to friction with the
united states and in the fall of 63
these two problems the reaction to his
his policies within south vietnam and
the friction with the united states
combined to bring about uh zm's downfall
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you for a great presentation
uh i'm pleased to present a pier aslan
assistant professor of history at hawaii
pacific university
uh his book is hanoi's war to the
vietnam war 1954 1965.
and i believe it was published this year
uh i want to thank the the the
organizers for for inviting me to
participate it's it's a real honor to be
amongst you guys tonight so thank you
very much for that
uh
before i begin just a quick disclaimer
i'm not french i'm french canadian i'm
not here to vin i'm not here to
vindicate grandpa who died at jian bien
fu i just watched rambo one too many
times as a kid and so and i got into the
whole vietnam thing that way so there's
i have no personal connection to
to to vietnam uh the the i'm gonna talk
to you tonight about about the year 63
in north vietnam which which 63 was a
big year in the us it was a huge year in
south vietnam um i i maintained that in
north vietnam it was a monumental year
this this was a a a watershed moment in
the history of the so-called vietnamese
communist revolution and i'll try and
shed some light uh on that with you with
you tonight
the research uh this this the pro this
is a product of research i've conducted
in in archives in vietnam
um
also in archives in france the uk and
canada uh because those were the only
three western countries allowed to keep
a diplomatic mission in north vietnam in
hanoi after 1954.
the u.s was there but the americans get
kicked out in 55. the french are there
because technically they're responsible
for implementing the geneva accords so
they get to stay the brits are there
because they were co-chairman of the
geneva conference they get to stay and
the canadians are there because they're
just nice people now i'm just there
there the canadians are there because
they're part of this supervisory
commission
to to to to uh help the different
parties uh apply apply the geneva
accords and so so so their diplomats in
hanoi are reporting back to their home
governments and those archives are
really really valuable to get a sense of
what's going on in hanoi because
there's stuff in vietnam it's hard to
get but it's there but the thing is the
vietnamese aren't particularly
forthcoming in terms of sharing their
archives with with with foreign scholars
even with their own scholars the history
of the vietnam war for hanoi is
basically
the government's property the party's
property and and so so it's it it pauses
a variety of different challenges
uh
let me see if this
okay there we go so so as as uh i'm sure
you're all
familiar with in 1954 in mid 1954 uh the
the communist leadership
uh enters into the the geneva accords
with france uh which effectively put an
end to the indo-china war um
now we always talk about the french were
forced to sign the accords because of
dnb and foo the indian foo was just one
battle in a long war yes the vietnam the
communists won that battle but the war
itself wasn't going all that great for
them and so so so when they enter into
the the geneva accords it's it's for a
variety of reasons number one ho chi
minh and the communists are absolutely
terrified of the us intervention by
mid-54 they recognize the us as the
vietnamese revolution's number one enemy
and as far as their concern if the war
doesn't end the americans will intervene
so they signed the accords to preclude a
u.s intervention beyond that they signed
the accords because they think they're
workable they think that they if they if
they if they accept those accords if if
the french abide by them if they abide
by them within two years the country is
going to be reunified under communist
governance they're confident that those
accords can actually work and
essentially bring about what an
eight-year war against france could not
the reunification of the country again
under their governance which is which is
really their their central goal
uh and and after 54 and four four
uh essentially five years or six years
after that
basically the communist revolutionary
strategy is what they call peaceful
struggle
political activity in the south
diplomatic initiatives internationally
to increase the pressure on saigon and
washington to respect the terms of the
geneva accords and even after 56 when
the deadline to hold the elections
passes with with no progress on that
front the leadership in hanoi continues
to press
for peaceful struggle continues to hope
that that vietnam can be reunified under
their governance through a diplomatic
arrangement
ideally the the geneva accords or else
something similar to to the 54 accords
in 1959 hanoi will authorize the onset
of insurgent activity in south vietnam
but it does that really against its own
will
the leadership ho chi minh specifically
is concerned that if we instigate an
insurgency again the americans might use
it as a pretext to become involved but
but there's pressure from within the
south
basically calling for
hanoi to authorize
insurgent activity below the 17th
parallel and so so so in 59 an
insurgency begins but it's it's it's
really a limited insurgency and it's one
which will not be
very uh strongly supported by by hanoi
they'll send some guns
they'll send personnel but most of these
guys are not actual northerners they're
southerners who had regrouped to the
north after 54
in accordance with the terms of the
geneva accords who were now being
dispatched back to the south as
volunteer troops not as north vietnamese
army regulars northerners are not
involved in the insurgency that begins
in in in 1959
now
how's decision to enter into the geneva
accords in 54 and then his decision to
wage peaceful struggle afterwards did
not sit well with everyone within the
party especially
with combatants and cadres and leaders
in the south
a number of these guys who stayed behind
after the geneva accords or else who
regrouped to the north we're really
disappointed that the leadership that ho
and the communist leadership did not try
to take advantage of the momentum
created by gen bien fu to really press
the fight until complete victory against
against the french and basically what
happens by 1963 is that we have a split
within the party we have a party that's
basically torn apart uh
split into two factions
moderates
i guess doves we'd call them in this
country on the one hand and then
militants or hawks on on on the other
hand and essentially the moderates
they're the ones controlling
communist decision making they're led by
ho chi minh and these guys basically
want to maintain peace at all cost to
preclude an american intervention
the the the militants on the other hand
the hawks within the party a number of
whom had fought against the french in
the south or else were from the south
originally are basically seeing war as
necessary to quote unquote liberate the
south and achieve national reunification
so we have this kind of impetuous
faction
which which since 54 has been pressuring
hanoi to be more proactive in in the
south which starts gaining more and more
momentum uh in in in the early 1960s
uh and we've talked about it the battle
of abbach earlier uh the impact
on on the communist leadership is is is
extremely significant
basically in 63 the militants become
emboldened and they gain much wider
support from within the party because of
a series of events the first one was the
outcome of the cuban missile crisis
which discredits khrushchev and the
whole idea of peaceful coexistence the
whole idea that you can basically
negotiate with the west with the united
states uh
the year before uh a set of accords on
neutralizing laos had been signed by 63
those accords start falling apart and
the militants will use it as proof again
that you can't negotiate with the
americans then there's the battle of
abac which they see as definitive proof
that now is as good a time as ever to
press the fight against the south
because that is weak
siem is weak the americans are not yet
interested in intervening in vietnam so
we should strike now
then there's what's going on in china
early 60s chinese foreign policy becomes
significantly more radical
chinese domestic and foreign policy is
basically undergoing a process of
radicalization
that same year 6263 for the first time
beijing starts encouraging the
vietnamese to fight until then despite
their calls for violent national
liberation in the third world the
chinese had no interest in another war
in vietnam they did not want a repeat of
what had happened in korea but by 6263
now they favor war in in vietnam and
then there's the signing of the partial
nuclear test ban treaty in in the summer
of 63 uh and and and this will really
alienate the chinese because they see
this as soviet and american collusion to
prevent china from having the bomb
and and in that perception the chinese
will be supported by the vietnamese uh
vietnamese militants in particular will
see the soviet decision to enter into
the treaty with the americans as
basically a sellout of china and of the
national liberation cause in in in the
third world
uh
here are the faces of the two camps uh
we're all familiar with ho chi minh ho
chi minh is the leader of the moderate
camp the other guy we don't know but yet
as as as robert and john have suggested
he's an extremely important individual
islam is lays one or laid one uh he will
eventually take over party decision
making and this is the guy who basically
wages the war against the united states
ho chi minh has nothing to do with
policy making after 65 during the war
against the us vongenzapp has been
sidelined we may have read the
obituaries recently talking about the
terror offensive as the product of
zapp's military genius zap had nothing
to do with the that offensive it was all
lays one's work this is the guy he
becomes the mao of vietnam the stalin of
vietnam the guy who basically will run
things in hanoi with an iron hand
november 63 as as as uh we've been
discussing as jessica and have mentioned
nordingziem is overthrown in the south
and and and this has huge significance
for the north basically it brings the
conflict between militants and moderates
to ahead and i claim that basically
within a few days after ziem is
overthrown in saigon there's a coup of a
different kind in the north
when militants basically sees the reigns
of power in hanoi they take over
decision making in hanoi so so so in in
november december basically militants
stage a coup of their own they take over
communist decision making they proceed
to purge moderates including ho chi minh
and vuong and zap and then they endorse
uh a really important resolution i'll be
talking about tomorrow uh resolution
nine which calls for immediate
quote-unquote decisive victory over
enemy forces in south vietnam
as early as january 64 we see a massive
increase in in in the quantity and the
quality of weapons that the north is
sending to insurgents in the south and
then a few months later in october
november the first combat units of the
north's armed forces the people's army
of vietnam or the nva are dispatched to
uh go and fight against the saigon
regime
essentially the changes we see unfolding
in hanoi in 63
the the the militant coup against
moderates and specifically resolution 9
will set north vietnam on this
irreversible collision course with the
united states
resolution nine and its attendant full
commitment of the north to the
liberation of south vietnam in my
opinion marks the real beginning of the
vietnam war when johnson deploys the
troops in 65 it's really to join a war
that's already ongoing the decision to
start bombing the north and to dispatch
the marines is basically a reaction to
initiatives undertaken by hanoi in 6364
vietnamese communist leaders start a
major war they thought they could win
before the u.s entered the fight they
gambled and they lost thank you
[Applause]
okay we have a lot of questions i'm sure
so we will
have more questions tomorrow
and
we will have more time
those who don't have the
opportunity to ask a question make a
note and give us the piece of paper if
if you're not going to be here tomorrow
but i hope you all come so let's go on
with the first question
jessica chapman reminded us that all
politics is la are local
american politicians know this
in this country but the state department
doesn't seem to understand it in other
countries
it's like they get a hold of facts
but they're simply to exploit
differences
such as we send anthropologists to you
know afghanistan to find splits and
exploitable
uh things
and then the military is the one that's
left to follow up on the policy i'm
wondering if uh
any or all of you would care to comment
on that the failure to understand that
the politics are local in other places
um yes thank you very much that's one of
the central arguments of my book is that
looking at the case of vietnam and the
ways in which american policy makers
failed
apprehend the complexities of south
vietnamese domestic politics not just
during the moment in which the united
states became interested in it but in
the sort of longer term in which its
character became evident
was a major flaw in american foreign
policy and that
looking at vietnam
as a cold war battleground that could be
defined and perceived in cold war terms
was the kind of fundamental problem and
i think you know ed's work demonstrates
in many ways that the united states
became
[Music]
intimately familiar i think with certain
vietnamese politicians and
kind of
because of the blinders that they put on
tended to
put too much emphasis on those
individuals and their outlooks and kind
of would in some in some cases and now
i'm not i'm putting words in ed's mouth
but i perceive that they
read what was happening in vietnam
through the perception of figures like
zm and that perception was flawed you
know zam would often times sort of make
comments about the domestic political
sphere in which he operated saying that
it was so so chaotic and people were so
you know politically underdeveloped that
that
certain
policies which were perceived by his
constituents as oppressive were actually
necessary in his eyes and so there was
some kind of
way in which americans were getting
their information about vietnam through
sources that they might have wanted to
interrogate a little bit more closely
than they did and that of course
happened with the earliest information
they were getting about vietnam which
was through the french which they then
kind of filtered through their own
existing preconceptions um and there
wasn't an intimacy with the the entire
range of what was happening in south
vietnam that would have maybe enabled
them to perceive it differently and make
different decisions about how to handle
um handle the situation
yeah
um i guess in response to the question
following up on some things that jessica
said
um
i i think you're right that actually
over the course of the vietnam war the
united states and certain americans
actually do acquire an extraordinary
knowledge of of vietnamese politics
certainly after the the americanization
of the war in 1965 you have
americans who who live out in the
provinces who often become very
knowledgeable about particular areas and
who really learn the the politics
backwards and forwards and i think
actually even in the earlier period that
that jessica and i have have written
about there are some diplomats who are
who are in the um the the embassy in in
saigon uh who were in the consulate in
inaudible prior to 1954 uh who really
have their ear to the ground and who
really pick up a lot if you read the
dispatches of somebody like edmund
gullion who is the charge da faire in in
saigon in the early 1950s this guy is
really paying attention to all of the
different
uh
divisions among vietnam vietnam's
anti-communist groups
um
and and this this perhaps points to
another area where where jessica and i
are perhaps somewhat different um i
think there are americans in 1954 uh who
are very skeptical of zm and i the way i
see the american view of exam in 1954 is
that there's a division and in some
cases that the skepticism is based on
some pretty serious knowledge of
vietnamese politics at the time so
not in the case of ambassador douglas
dillon i mean he was in france he didn't
know anything about vietnam
but there are other people
in vietnam people like paul sturm who
had been the consul in hanoi who had
very close ties to groups like daviette
he was a big proponent of fanhui quad
who was the leader of one of the
factions of the dive yet and this gets
picked up by some other americans like
edward lansdale who's trying to pressure
zm to bring quad into his cabinet and
and zam is is resisting that so so this
is not a case in which the united states
doesn't know anything about vietnamese
politics and it just sort of back exam
by default it's it's it's much more
complicated than that and in some cases
americans actually do know a lot about
vietnam um this is a case where we
really have to take account of zam's
agency and zam's ability uh in in some
cases to resist um some of these these
american prescriptions so i i think
it's not just a lack of information in
some cases there is information there
it's what you do with it that i think
really makes a big difference
um
i have a bit of trouble with that
question because
of
um
because of the nation state and national
power you know
yes it's true everything that that
jessica and ed are saying
about how some even in the state
department
[Music]
understand the vietnamese politics and
yes it's also true the premise of your
question that all politics is local and
why is it that the united states somehow
never understands these things that are
going on in other countries
but
the the place where this sort of goes
fuzzy is that
the function of the state department is
to implement american national policy
and to
gain national objectives that are set by
the american government so in a sense
its function is
specifically
to
go against local local politics where
they are and somehow turn them
in america's favor
right
um
now having said that
the
key rejoinder would then be you know
well did the state department succeed in
turning vietnamese politics into the
direction that the americans wanted
and that's actually where we come back
to mr ziam and 1963
kennedy is frustrated that for
everything we're doing for the
vietnamese for all the money that we're
giving them and the troops we're sending
to vietnam
we can't get cm to do what we want to do
so
yes
we did or did not understand their
politics as local and no we were not
successful in turning them in the
direction we wanted
in
1965 uh margaret higgins wrote a book
called our vietnam nightmare um so those
of you who are familiar of it uh with it
how does uh her history her book stand
up to your research
uh yeah higgins is a very colorful
figure and and her book is is certainly
an interesting and and entertaining read
i think in in some ways it's a good
example of of of reportage she in her
book she she relates um some of the
the experiences she had she was in
vietnam in 1963
during uh
during certain portions of the buddhist
crisis and she actually interviewed jim
twice in august of 63.
and uh those interviews are actually
very important i think in understanding
exams state of mind in the weeks leading
up to the crackdown on the the buddhist
crisis
i do think that higgins um
view of affairs was
colored by
her very sort of hard-line
anti-communist views and especially by
her sympathy for cm i mean zam can
really do
no wrong uh which is why zam granted her
those interviews at that critical moment
because he knew that she could be
counted on to write very sympathetically
around him about him uh the the other
thing that's that's very memorable about
um
marguerite higgins uh i mean the book is
in some ways almost a memoir and she was
back in washington in november when the
coup took place and according to her i
don't know if roger hillsman ever
confirmed the story but hillsman of
course was a state department official
uh one of the state department officials
who did push very hard for for the coup
and um afterwards many people in vietnam
in the united states sort of blamed
hillsborough um for for the coup
and according to higgins she called
hillsman up at three o'clock in the
morning like the next day after the coup
or something and she said
how does it feel to have blood on your
hands roger
and and roger said oh maggie you know
this is a revolution people get hurt go
back to bed or at least that's that's
the way she
she she related i i don't know if
hillsman uh ever told his side of the
story or not
i wonder uh especially for uh
the two are talking about zm um
neither of you had a chance to read the
new book on madame new and if that's
changed uh any of your viewpoints on zm
because it has uh i think uh unpublished
memoir that uh she's finally they've
kind of finally put out
yeah i
i have not seen the um the previously
unpublished
well
there's actually two texts uh authored
by by matamu there's a memoir
and then there's also a diary and the
the memoir i'm i'm pretty sure is is
legitimate because i i never met matamu
while she was alive but there were a
number of people i i spoke to including
uh monique bryson demery who's the
author of the recent book
and um
i think that demary got the memoir from
madame new the the diary has a much more
unclear provenance and it supposedly
surfaced in vietnam in the 60s and then
but the chain of custody is a little bit
uh hard to pin down so um
there's some uncertainty there um i i
saw portions of the book in in draft
form i haven't i have to confess i
haven't seen the um the published uh
version yet um i think that from what
i've seen from demary's work uh she's to
be commended for um taking madame new
seriously because if sam has been
caricatures i uh suggested matamu has
been even more caricatured
um
i i think there are some important
questions about madame knew that that at
least from what i've seen of demery's
work she leaves unanswered uh things
like her feminism madame considered
herself a feminist and even though her
feminism is not what most americans
would recognize as feminism that was
still a very integral part of her and
her political program
so i think there's still a lot more
interesting research that could be done
on madame mew
well first of all with a comment of
margaret higgins uh you guys will recall
that uh margaret higgins attacked the
saigon press corps
in 6263 she called malcolm brown and
halberstam and all those guys
unpatriotic because of their reportage
and madame knew of course when she made
her famous comment uh about the uh
immolation of the buddhist monks
she actually provoked the first anti-war
demonstrations on her tour in the united
states there were demonstrates that
colombia a friend of mine's mother was
involved in that demonstration
now i wanted to ask a question about the
period from 54
to 59
this is a very controversial period in
vietnam
and i want to ask the question about
what your understanding is now
of what the viet minh the stay behinds
were doing
uh what was going on on the ground
there's always controversy about this
when
the
new
arvin
military which was a french colonial
force in the main
transformed into the army of the
republic of vietnam which still hasn't
been really clarified and even bob
brigham's book doesn't really clarify
that
what happened in the ground from your
understanding with new work from 54 to
59 with the vietnam vietnamese
communists stay behind
in all the different areas of the
country some argue that land reform was
thrown back
in certain areas
some people argue landlords
made people pay back rent so what do you
guys understand from your knowledge
uh because a lot of us are pretty well
informed about this out here too
what happened
okay can i
all right so so the the orders coming
from hanoi are very very from the
leadership are very very clear communist
combatants have to regroup to the north
they have to stand down they can't fight
they have to regroup to the north uh now
some some communist cadres can stay in
the south and they actually order close
to 10 000 cadres to stay in the south
but those are political cadres which
under the terms of the geneva accords
can't stay in the south but the
combatants have to go to the north now
based on stuff i found in the french
archives it looks like a significant
number of southern combatants decided
not to go to the north basically acted
against contravene the orders they were
given by by by their superiors
54-59
hanoi is very clear we are not to resume
armed struggle as i as i suggested as i
pointed out my presentation but what
will happen is that a number of
vietnamese
uh will then start joining other
organizations which they see are doing
more to actually take action against
them including the sex that jessica
talked about a number of viet ming will
basically break rank they'll they'll
join other organizations or else they'll
start taking independent action and
those were a huge liability for hanoi
hanoi was very concerned about those
guys
in 59 there's a bunch of uprisings that
take place and and the understanding was
that those uprisings take place in the
south because hanoi has finally given
those guys authorization and now what
we're realizing is that in a number of
places in the south those uprisings are
taking place actually days if not weeks
before the authorization to take action
comes from from hanoi so so hanoi is is
having a hard time controlling
the the vietnamese elements who stay in
the south after 54. but as far as the
directives are concerned they're very
very clear
vietnam communist combatants are to take
no action that would basically break the
latter or the spirit of the geneva
accords
um i i would just add to that as far as
what's going on in the ground certainly
uh there is um
some roll back in those areas that had
been controlled by the viet minh where
their the viet minh had carried out some
some redistribution of land there is
some
rollback of of that sam passes a
rent reduction law in early 1955 or he
he decree issues a rent reduction decree
which which has the effect of of
allowing uh some land owners to to go
back and claim land that they had
previously uh that had had previously
been redistributed by by the viet minh
um however uh the situation there is a
little bit more complicated than the way
it's often been represented uh some
scholars have looked at ziem's
measures they've also looked at his
unwillingness to go very far with his
own land reform program and said look
sam wasn't interested in agrarian reform
he basically favored the rural status
quo in in south vietnam returned to the
pre-war status quo
and uh i argue against that i think that
that zm actually just had a different
vision of agrarian transformation and
whereas the americans were calling for
thoroughgoing land reform for
redistributing the land zam's approach
to agrarian reform emphasized
redistributing the people this is why he
was so into resettlement and into moving
people around and especially moving
people from crowded areas or areas he
saw as crowded in south vietnam into
other parts of the country that that
were lightly populated or unpopulated so
there's quite a lot that's going on on
the ground in in various aspects of the
country as as far as the cadres after
about 1956 the the overwhelmingly
dominant feature that they have to
contend with is zam's crackdown
which is really really effective in 1957
and 1958 and the the communist sources
on this are quite clear uh especially
the stuff that's been published since
1975. uh in many districts of the south
uh the uh the dm's uh success security
forces succeed in rolling up 90 or more
of the cadres and in some cases the the
party apparatus has effectively ceased
to function and they can't fight back
basically hanoi is telling them in spite
of all that's going on you guys can't
fight back and that's when 59 hanoi says
okay now you can fight back but only to
protect yourselves from zim not to
actually work to overthrow him right and
and i think there is the sense that a
lot of the southern cadres are saying
look we're getting killed we have no
choice and and i i think you're right i
think david elliot has shown that there
are very clear cases of these uprisings
taking place before the news of
resolution 15 has been has been
transferred to the south um so so
there's quite a lot that's going on um
in the south in the
rural areas at this time
the only other thing i would add to that
is that not
all of the activity that was attributed
to viet cong had anything to do with
these communist categories building on
on pierre's point that it was the way
that zam defined viet cong to be anybody
who opposed the government
whether they be communist or
non-communists that sort of led to that
conflation of all anti-government
activity as being viet cong and and i
think in fact framed all of that
opposition in a way that actually
encouraged it to unify against him and
you make that point in your book
after 54 the main opposition to yemen
the south is not the communists it's the
religious sects the communists are not a
threat at all to them relative to to to
the sex
from certain presentations my question
is regarding the
military coup in south vietnam uh
someone mentioned there was some
division of opinions within the kennedy
administration
and i'm just wondering
what was the actual position of the
president kennedy and the vice president
johnson on this uh
quote were they in support of all
john you want to take that
um vice president johnson was certainly
against the coup
no question
johnson had visited northern ziem in the
spring of 1961 on a tour
of asia
had
considered
ziem his friend
and
was a stalwart supporter of ziem
through thick and thin
right until the day of the coup when zm
was killed
john kennedy is a more complex character
i was thinking about that earlier today
as a matter of fact
you know
if you look at kennedy's actions in the
major foreign policy foreign policy
crises of his presidency
cuban missile crisis of course comes
right up the berlin wall crisis
the bay of pigs and now what happens in
vietnam in 1963
okay
i think what you would encounter
is
a gentleman who
always had a clear idea of where he was
going
it's true that in the cuban crisis
kennedy stood back
and let his chief advisers sort of
debate amongst each other amongst
themselves what direction that they
should go in but in all the other cases
what kennedy did was basically to go
around the table and say to each one
okay are you good with this whatever it
was that they were considering doing
and when this question of the coup in
south vietnam comes up i believe that's
essentially what kennedy does now some
of my colleagues may disagree with this
and we can have this debate
but um
i think that the evidence is there
that kennedy took a certain position
in favor of
sort of forcing saigon to move ahead
in the direction the united states
wanted
no matter whether that meant getting rid
of nordenziam
fundamentally they wanted to get rid of
the people around ziam new madame knew
the nuo family but
if
ziam would not agree to that and it was
a fair bet that zam would not agree to
that then zm had to go
now
there exists
a
a tape
kennedy had a taping system you know
and he could choose what meetings in the
oval office flick a button and tape them
and the tape is
kennedy's meeting with henry cabot lodge
whom he was appointing to be
whom he was appointing to become
ambassador to saigon this is in the
middle of august of 1963.
this is before anyone is talking about a
coup
and before any of this other stuff has
ever happened
and
kennedy tells lodge
that
one of his big jobs in saigon is going
to be to deal with the problem of ziem
and that that may require a coup and if
it does require a coup lodge is going to
be in charge of making it work
essentially
so i think kennedy already had that idea
in his head
early
i
i haven't heard that particular tape
is that recently
declassified uh not recent but it's not
well known okay um that that's very
interesting i certainly look forward to
hearing that the the way i look at
kennedy and
and his whole approach to vietnam in
1963 and actually earlier as well
i think that kennedy's fundamental
impulse in vietnam was to try to keep
his options
was to try to
to keep his maximum room for maneuver
with everything
um the moment at which kennedy crosses
the line and endorses regime change
comes with the august 24th cable that uh
that bob mentioned at the outset of the
proceedings this evening
and
that that cable is very controversial
the way it's drafted by hillsman and
forrest all the way is transmitted to to
saigon
and it becomes a big subject of debate
both at the time and afterwards but
kennedy does not recall it kennedy does
not change it but that doesn't mean that
he sort of switched over and he said
well we're definitely going to have a
coup now what it means is is that the
coup option is on the proverbial table
and i think this is relevant to
understanding not just the issue of the
coup but also of course the very
contentious issue of the kennedy
withdrawal i don't think kennedy had
made a definite decision about what to
do with vietnam i think withdrawal was
one possibility i think going in bigger
was one possibility for him in 1963.
in uh
in the year uh
1963 i was 14 or 15 years old but one
one thing i remember was the the the
name of cardinal spellman came up a lot
in the united states and i'm just one
and he's very close to the kennedys as
well as the dm the dm government the
people in gym and the nose and i'm
wondering what kind of influence he did
have at that time
thank you
um
go ahead joe i'm sorry
are we okay here
um
i think that cardinal spellman had
considerable influence
on
the american press
on the sort of public presentation of
vietnam as an issue in the united states
i think that
in the late 1950s and going into the 60s
he had a more direct political influence
inside the american government
but
that i believe diminished in part
because kennedy himself
understood that he needed to bend over
backwards in order to
not
appear to be
responding to catholics
and roman catholicism as a political
influence on him
that was a major issue in the 1960
election
kennedy was facing a re-electoral
campaign in 1964
i'll just add to that i i think i
mostly agree with that
the issue of of spelman's influence is
is most often about in connection with
zam with his appointment in 1954. and i
think this is another issue on which um
jessica and i will will have to agree to
disagree um
spellman was very close to the goal
brothers the connection was through
the uh the older brother who became the
archbishop they had studied in rome uh
together in the 1920s so they went way
back and
the the catholic networks that
that that that spellman has access to
the international catholic networks are
very important for zm especially when
he's in exile in the united states and
europe in the early uh 1950s
um
there's no evidence though that spellman
played any role in securing zam's
appointment in 1954 as has often been
alleged there's just none there's no
reliable evidence of this it's been long
asserted going back to this um poorly
sourced article that was published by
robert shear and warren hinkle in the
1960s
but no one has ever come forward there's
there's there's no evidence to support
this um
spelman did have a lot of connections
with people in congress
a lot of these people in congress
especially catholic members of congress
people like kennedy kennedy met ziem in
1953 when he was in the u.s they really
liked jim a lot but if you look at dm's
interactions with executive branch
officials with officials first in the
truman administration and then in the
eisenhower administration zm bombs every
single time so there's really no
evidence that that zm during this period
of his exile in the united states is um
is is making these connections in the
executive branch which will then
translate into some kind of u.s pressure
campaign uh on behalf of his appointment
in 1954. there there's there's just no
evidence to to support that that i've
seen and and no one's been able to
produce it i've been saying this for a
long time historians continue to assert
it but no one comes forward with the
evidence
thank you imagine if our founders have
been foolish enough to believe
that all politics is local
this question is directed to john
your colleagues seemed to want to blame
the
vietnamese
for the
conflict it was never a war
mcmaster wrote a book about the
dereliction of duty by the joint chiefs
of staff can you say something about the
dereliction of duty by the state
department
and cia
specifically in terms of a particular
family that was controlling both and
their sister
repeat that last part
the dulles the dulles brothers one in
charge of the state department the other
charge of the cia and their sister the
dereliction of duty by the cia and the
state department in terms of
the conflict caused in 1963 as opposed
to blaming it on the vietnamese
okay so we're going back to the 1950s
here we're talking about the eisenhower
administration during which time alan
dulles is the chief of the cia and his
brother john foster dulles is the
secretary of state and
their sister is an assistant secretary
of state
so
this is
certainly a case of
i don't know the family that
the family that does something together
does something together
dulles the two dulles brothers
um
absent eleanor at this point going back
to 1955 and the sex and the battle of
saigon there is to this day an existing
mystery about
what happened
during those
days
uh no denziem was on the brink of
either
great success or
crashing in flames
in his contest with the political
religious sects
in saigon in 1955
and
ed lansdale who was a subordinate cia
officer was agitating for the cia to
take an active role in support of ziem
and
the dulles brothers were
in
a
cat bird position in washington dc with
president dwight eisenhower deciding
what to do in this crisis in saigon
during which his personal friend
an army general named jay lawton collins
whom he had
appointed as ambassador to saigon as
well as his
presidential representative in south
vietnam
was recommending that the united states
remove support from zm because he had
concluded that zm was not going to make
the reforms that needed to be made and
that his uh
[Music]
his power could not endure
well a moment comes
where eisenhower in fact is convinced by
collins and
induces john foster dulles to go along
with
issuing the order to
remove support from zm with all that
that entailed for the united states and
suddenly that
state department directive is
countermanded
within a matter of about less than two
days
and during that interval there is an
exchange of communications between
lansdale and allen dulles and there's a
private meeting between allen and john
foster
so
that is at least one
explicit instance where
something along the lines of what you're
talking about actually did happen in u.s
policy
i would just add
to to that account i i agree with with
john's um
uh chronology here
but the thing that happens in the
interim is the start of the battle of
saigon
and
it is
it is
prior to the battle of saigon
a lot of people think that this thing
could go either way
but in retrospect i think the evidence
shows pretty clearly that jim had the
upper hand and that zam actually had
been looking for several weeks for an
excuse to start the battle because he
knew
that his support within the vietnam
national army which becomes the arvind
has been shored up uh he and his
brothers had done their work very well
in recruiting the the forces and in the
end the resistance that comes from the
benjamin and the gowdain the wahawa when
push comes to shove
they they really don't acquit themselves
uh very well at all the the vietnam
national army gets the upper hand um in
about two days in the battle of saigon
and in the subsequent campaigns against
um gaodai and and hua hao forces in the
delta
um
zm is able to execute this this divide
and conquer strategy
so
so yes there are these communications
that are going these back channel
communications between people like
lansdale and dulles but we should not
conclude from that
that that those are the most important
things and that everything that happens
in south vietnam in 1954 and 55 turns on
the actions of of edward landsdale um i
would just
uh finish up by saying in response to
the question
um the way i see the vietnam war is
there's plenty of blame to go around so
i i do not
um by by suggesting that that vietnamese
actors have some agency and some
responsibility here i do not mean to
suggest that that american actors do not
also have agency and responsibility they
certainly do
um
remind me now this chronology
if i'm not mistaken battle of saigon
breaks out around 28 26 27th 28th of
march 55 28th april right
now there are two there are two in the
beginning successive
stages of it well the first one's in
march one's in april
end of march right and okay museum
thought
that that was it dan felt that that his
troops were in position and the
frenchman would be
blocked okay and collins makes a trip
back to washington that's that comes in
april that's in april right before the
second stage of the battle okay
so there's the first stage of the battle
and um
it's
on edge in saigon collins goes back to
washington
i believe that this meeting between the
two dulles brothers is on the 17th of
april the records of it by the way are
still classified
i've been trying to get them open for
years but that's another issue
and then
colin succeeds in getting this this
order issued he gets on a plane to go
back to saigon just before the second
stage of that battle breaks out and his
plane is detained in hawaii
for nearly two days and while
collins is stuck in hawaii and unable to
execute this order
the battle starts i think he was still
in still in washington he was still in
washington when the battle starts
yeah the the the time period between the
issuing of the cable
that you know
telling the embassy to contact the
french and look for alternative
leadership and its recall is actually
shorter than two days it's about six
hours as i remember yes that's right and
that's right and
so that comes out collins is directly
suited is the point right but he's still
in washington at that time so i mean he
may be delayed going back to saigon
afterwards
but the the critical decisions and the
critical developments of saigon take
place while he's still in washington
i'm
quite sure
uh gentlemen ladies and gentlemen uh two
questions one very short and one little
bit longer uh the short question uh did
the folks who were being typed by john f
kennedy did they know they were being
taped i'm wondering but the
second question is frankly
how do you know how many people in south
vietnam in 1963
really wanted to be ruled by a communist
dictatorship i mean we know in
retrospect that the rule of late juan
was was horrific when he died in 86 it
was a great day for the vietnamese
people but
even in 1963 they had the example of
north korea and china which already had
gone through collectivization two
horrific events
um
what was the real popularity of
the notion of communist dictatorship
rule in south vietnam
questionnaire pierre can take the other
robert mcnamara once said
that if you sat around the cabinet table
and you
looked at the way that the president
looked at you
during the meetings
you
had to assume you were being taped
the only people who really understood
marxism leninism in vietnam were the
core leaders in hanoi the guys in the
south even even even high-ranking cadres
in the south didn't really understand
what the whole thing was about and and
as it turns out
the the directors were coming from the
party basically telling telling
subordinates to always present the
vietnamese revolution as a nationalist
revolution so the idea was that you know
we were going to be fight as one and
once it was over then we would have the
second revolution the socialist
revolution where we would proceed to
implement this you know that the the
society that marxism or marxism dictated
would would go on so so so the movement
is popular in the south because it it
presents itself as a as an anti-american
anti-gm pro-vietnamese movement
uh and it's it's in the south anyway
it's not until after 75 that people then
get to see really what the objective was
against for the core leaders in hanoi
and and that that's why that story is is
important is that when we look at why
people were fighting in vietnam on the
communist side uh there's there's
there's there there the reasons that are
motivating the leadership in hanoi are
very very different from what's
motivating
the guys doing the fighting in in in the
south which i guess is no different from
the american experience in in
in that war so so yeah to say that you
know
those were communists we're going to use
the term very very loosely
the real communists were in hanoi les
one i i maintain in the book was
extremely dogmatic really really
ideological
and approached the war as as a necessity
not just to liberate vietnam but
basically to defeat imperialism around
the world these are guys who believe in
this idea of world revolution and in
serving as a model for for national
liberation just like castro after his
revolution starts investing a lot in
promoting national liberation in africa
and elsewhere the vietnamese have the
same designs the leadership has the same
designs in terms of making the
vietnamese revolution an example for
those fighting against the us against
imperialism and against reactionary
forces everywhere
we have to stop here
please hold your questions for tomorrow
and thank you for coming
[Applause]